Hand hinauf, wer von auch hat auch bis jetzt gedacht, das er ein guter Autofahrer ist?
Und jetzt müssen wir da unten durch?
Ah f* da hat es Fahrverbot.
Das ist aber eine ganz linke Tour die du da mit mir durchziehst.
Willkommen in der Fahrschule.
Ist das jetzt die Hitze? Ich bin völlig erledigt.
Wirklich?
Ja.
Man möchte es ja möglichst schnell hinter sich haben,
aber im Zweifelsfall nimmt man besser noch eine weitere Fahrstunde.
Oh.
Entschuldigung.
Oh je.
Am morgen um 7:30 Uhr kommt jemand und sagt:
Frau Vetsch, sie dürfen jetzt gleich eine Fahrprüfung antreten.
Jackpot.
Los geht's.
Drei Tage unter Fahrlehrern.
Das ist "Mona mittendrin".
Da vorne Richtung Flughafen.
- Jawohl.
(25 Jahre fahre ich schon Auto,
aber mit dem Experten auf dem
Beifahrersitz habe ich ein Deja-vu.)
Es fühlt sich wirklich an
wie bei der Fahrprüfung.
Und es ist kein gutes Gefühl.
- Sicher? - Ja!
Hast du beim ersten Mal bestanden?
Nein.
- Okay.
Wir können da vorne rechts ...
Du kannst selbst entscheiden,
wo du ein Rückwärts-
seitwärts-Parkieren machst.
Hier?
- Ja. - Okay.
* Piepen *
Dazu kann man gar nichts sagen.
Bist du selber froh oder verblüfft?
(Zugegeben:
Die Parklücke war ziemlich gross.)
(Aber seitwärts parkieren
kann ich wirklich.)
(Aber dann hört es offenbar
auch schon bald auf.)
Was man nicht gut sieht:
Du stehst permanent auf Kupplung.
Ist dir das auch schon aufgefallen?
- Ja. Ich weiss nicht, warum.
Du drückst sie immer sofort.
Das ist ein Sicherheitsdenken.
Am einfachsten drückst du nichts.
Nach dieser Metallbrücke geht es
links rauf. Dort, wo der Herr geht.
Hier einspuren.
Aber wie macht man das?
Das wäre jetzt ...
- ... voll falsch.
Das wäre voll falsch.
- Echt? Wie wäre es gegangen?
Auf die Busspur darfst du nicht.
- Ach! Hier habe ich sie erwischt.
Wäre ich durch die Prüfung gefallen?
- Das wäre negativ, ja.
Ehrlich? Oh, Scheibe!
Es reicht aber schon,
wie du die Kupplung drückst.
Nein! Deshalb würde ich durchfallen?
Nein! Sicher nicht.
Das ist klar ein technischer Fehler.
Das geht den doch nichts an,
ob ich kupple oder nicht.
Da ist auch ein Risiko dabei:
Wenn du in einer Kurve
die Kupplung loslässt,
kann es dich auf dem Eis drehen.
Ich fahre jetzt 25 Jahre und es hat
mich noch nie auf dem Eis gedreht.
Komm jetzt!
- Nicht? - Nein!
Dort vorne gehen wir nach links.
- Quatsch.
Ich wäre jetzt also
schon doppelt durchgefallen.
Hier links.
- Ja.
* Blinker *
Wenn ich ganz fies bin,
jetzt zum dritten Mal. - Wieso?
Wer hat Vortritt, er oder du?
- Er.
D.h., du hast ihm eigentlich
den Vortritt geklaut.
Gut. Danke schön.
* Blinker *
Also, um es festzuhalten: Wie oft
wäre ich schon durchgefallen?
Marco, sag es!
- Mario, ist egal. Aber dreimal.
Viermal, weil ich
deinen Namen falsch gesagt habe.
Genau, das ist eigentlich ...
Stimmt. - Ein absolutes No-Go.
Also, viermal durchgefallen.
- Genau.
Und jetzt gehen wir hier untendurch?
- Das wäre das fünfte Mal.
Was? Wieso schon wieder?
Was habe ich gemacht?
Hä? Ah! Fuck die Wand,
da ist ein Fahrverbot.
Das ist also eine ganz fiese Tour,
die du mit mir durchziehst.
Hier geht es gleich wieder links.
(Fazit: fünfmal durchgefallen.)
(Und das trotz 25 Jahren
hinter dem Steuer. Aua!)
Du kannst ihn
gerade auf die 30 stellen.
Rückwärts hier dazwischenstellen.
Ja.
- Genau.
Solche Sachen auch anzeigen.
- Jawohl.
Mit dem Blinker.
- Aha! Ah, ich?
Ja, genau.
- Scheibe.
(Ich parkiere vor der Zentrale
der Fahrschule Koch.)
(Die ist in Regensdorf, Zürich.)
Dann gehen wir rein
auf unseren verdienten Kaffee, oder?
Oh, la, la!
Morgen!
- Grüezi wohl! Guten Morgen!
Darf ich vorstellen?
- Claudia, freut mich. - Mona.
Beat, mein Geschäftspartner.
- Welcome! Schön!
Vielen Dank.
- Ging es gut?
Äh ... Teils, teils.
* Alle lachen. *
Die gute Nachricht:
Wir haben es überlebt.
Die schlechte:
Ich wäre sicher durchgefallen,
wenn es eine Prüfung gewesen wäre.
- Sicher?
Das wundert mich auch!
- Du fährst schon lange.
Eben! Das ist das Problem.
Und was ist dein Bild
von den Fahrlehrern? Hast du eins?
Wie ist für dich
die Fahrlehrerschaft?
Ich habe keinen Plan,
wieso man Fahrlehrer werden möchte.
Das ist sicher langweilig.
Man sitzt immer neben Knochen,
die nichts können,
und fährt dieselben Strecken.
- Ich mache es schon 25 Jahre.
Und ich bin noch nicht müde.
- Ehrlich? - Ja!
(Schlecht Auto fahren
und auch noch Vorurteile.)
(Aber zum Glück sind sich Fahrlehrer
so schwierige Fälle wie mich
gewohnt.)
Also, Herr Kandidat,
Sie dürfen losfahren. - Gut.
(Erste Lektion: Beat spielt den
Schüler, ich bin die Fahrlehrerin.)
Muss ich schon kontrollieren,
damit du keinen Mist machst?
Natürlich,
du hast die Verantwortung.
Gut. Du fährst hier geradeaus.
Äh ...
- Einfach geradeaus. 30 haben wir.
(Die Grundregel für Fahrlehrer:
auf alles gefasst sein,
frühzeitig Kommandos geben,
eingreifen wenn nötig.)
Jetzt hier ... Achtung, haben Sie
gesehen? Fussgänger! - Ah, ja.
(Und schon musste ich
zum ersten Mal reinbremsen.)
(Im Fahrschulauto hat es ja auch
auf meiner Seite Fusspedale.)
Gut.
* Blinker *
Ist gut, wenn ich jetzt schalte?
Ja, wir können
in den zweiten Gang schalten.
Nicht zu weit raus,
eher auf diese Seite. Jawohl.
Nicht zu stark, nicht zu stark.
Genau. So lassen wir
einem Velofahrer den nötigen Platz.
Kannst du mir noch mal zeigen ...
- Jawohl. Schön gerade. Genau.
Okay.
Wir halten hier mal an.
- Aha, wir halten an. Gut.
Ist das die Hitze?
Ich bin schon völlig erledigt.
Schon?
- Ja!
Komm jetzt!
- Gut. Anfahren am Berg.
Genau. Wenn es nicht funktioniert,
müsstest du intervenieren
und mir bitte helfen, bevor mir
der Schweiss hinunterläuft.
Ist das gut?
- Jawohl.
Also, wir fahren an. - Muss ich
schauen? Oder einfach losfahren?
Schön auf die Kupplung
beim Druckpunkt,
etwas Gas geben
und langsam kommen lassen.
Und den Verkehr beobachten?
- Ja, gern. Zuerst nach hinten ...
Boah! Kontrollblick!
Heiland noch mal!
Entschuldigung.
- Okay. - Ruhige Art.
Vermutlich hast du jetzt ...
die Kupplung zu schnell losgelassen.
Okay.
Jawohl, jawohl.
- Und dann?
Noch mal kurz ein Kontrollblick:
Kommt nichts? Jetzt ganz langsam.
Fast! Wir haben es fast geschafft.
Nächstes Mal schaffen wir es ganz.
Würdest du bitte übernehmen?
Ich kann momentan gerade nicht mehr.
Jawohl.
- Ich bin froh, hilfst du mir, Mona.
Ja, ich bin auch ganz froh.
So, etwas kommen lassen,
kommen lassen. Und jetzt ...
* Ruckeln *
... fährt es immer noch nicht.
Mona!
- Ich konnte es auch nicht.
Ich dachte,
du kannst mich hier etwas beruhigen.
(Beim vierten Versuch
klappt es endlich.)
(Er habe noch den dritten Gang
drin gehabt, sagt Beat später.)
(Ein kleiner Test.
Ich bin wieder durchgefallen.)
* Pulsierende Klänge *
(Die Fahrschule Koch
war bis vor zehn Jahren
ein kleines Familienunternehmen,
das Mario
von seinem Vater übernommen hat.)
(Dann stieg Beat ins Geschäft ein
und seither
sind sie jedes Jahr gewachsen.)
(Computerstimme)
... mit dem rechten Fuss ...
(Heute arbeiten hier
elf festangestellte Fahrlehrer
und -lehrerinnen.)
(Der Grillabend gehört aber
nicht mehr zur Arbeitszeit.)
(Mario) Im Fahrschulbereich bist du
in der Regel ein Einzelkämpfer.
Der Durchschnitt arbeitet allein.
- Wir kennen uns, seit wir 13 waren.
Wir haben dann mal
Blutsbrüderschaft gemacht,
wie sich das in dem Alter gehört.
- Nein!
Doch, mit 13.
Das war eine wichtige Zeit.
Ja, wir haben viel im Wald gespielt.
Die Töfflizeit war auch extrem.
- Die volle Jugend verbracht.
Frisiert und alles?
Mein Vater war Polizist,
ich sage nichts dazu.
Mein Vater war Fahrlehrer.
Ich bin auch ruhig.
Schön, Rosemarie!
Sie ist eigentlich
die wichtigste Person.
Ist das deine Mutter?
- Nein!
* Lachen *
Sie ist die Vermieterin?
Die Besitzerin dieses Hauses.
- Aha!
(Beim geselligen Teil
bin ich schon ein Vollmitglied.)
(Aber meine erste Stunde mit einem
Fahrschüler wartet noch auf mich.)
* Rhythmische Streicher-
und Schlagzeugklänge *
(Fahrlehrer stehen früh auf.)
Gern einen Kaffee?
(Sie müssen oft dann arbeiten,
wenn ihre Kunden Freizeit haben:
am Morgen, über Mittag
oder am Abend.)
Topmotiviert schon am frühen Morgen.
- Ja! Wir machen gleich Kaffee.
(Die Kaffeemaschine ist
nach dem Auto das wichtigste Gerät.)
Am Anfang fragte ich mich schon:
Wieso wird man Fahrlehrer?
Ich habe mir das vorher
ehrlich gesagt nie überlegt.
Wieso wird man Fahrlehrer?
Was ist das Coole daran?
Man muss Freude an Fahrzeugen haben.
Das ist sicher ein wichtiger Punkt.
Und man muss
Freude an Menschen haben.
Und die Herausforderung annehmen,
mit Menschen zu arbeiten,
ihnen etwas beizubringen
Es ist diese Kombination.
Und wir müssen
ab und zu geduldig sein.
Dann ist es ein toller Job. Man
hat nicht immer die gleichen Leute.
Im Büro hat man immer dieselben
Leute, wir immer wieder andere.
Das ist interessant.
Und oft ist man im Auto Psychologe.
Mit der Zeit
entsteht eine Beziehung.
Du bringst ihnen etwas bei,
sie sind offen.
Und man sitzt auf sehr engem Raum.
- Erzählen sie einem viel?
Ja, sehr viel.
(Vielleicht ist Fahrlehrerin sein
doch interessanter,
als ich mir das vorgestellt habe.
Ich erfahre es gleich.)
(Auf mich wartet
mein erster Fahrschüler, Joel.)
(Unter Beobachtung
von Fahrlehrer Lukas.)
Wir machen es so: Ich sage etwas
und du sagst, wie es richtig ist.
Ich höre mal zu.
- Gut.
Dann schauen wir es an.
- Tipptopp. Oh!
Entschuldigung!
- Oh!
Ist etwas passiert? Nur erschrocken?
- Alles gut!
Wir fahren jetzt
zuerst rückwärts raus,
dann vornedurch weg.
Es wäre schön, wenn wir beim
Rausfahren blinken würden. - Ah!
Die nächste links.
(Wir fahren auf ein ruhiges Gelände
beim Bahnhof Regensdorf.)
* Blinker, glockige Musik *
(Unsere Aufgabe heute:
rechtwinklig rückwärts parkieren.)
Du kannst ihn eigentlich
rückwärts in die 14 stellen.
Mhm.
Was muss ich da so beachten?
- Wie du das so machen musst?
Ja.
- Eine sehr gute Frage.
Soll ich hier mal nachschauen?
Ich würde einfach intuitiv
ungefähr wissen, wo. - Ja, klar.
* Piepen *
Also, Achtung: Seitwärtskorrektur.
Also: "Gleichmässig rollen
und lenken bis zum Anschlag."
"Wenn Fahrzeug gerade,
Räder im Stehen gerade stellen,
zurückfahren bis in Parkfeld."
Sagt dir das etwas?
Also vor dem zweiten Park...
Ah, nein! Ja, ist gut. Mhm!
* Jazzige Klänge *
Jetzt stehen wir in der Mitte.
- In der Mitte, ja.
Wie würdest du korrigieren?
- Noch mal vorwärts.
Was denkst du:
Wie viele Fahrstunden brauchst du?
Jetzt haben wir siebeneinhalb.
Etwa zwölf bis 15, schätze ich.
- Ja. Das ist eher wenig, oder?
Wie ich gehört habe, schon, ja.
- Ja.
Was hast du mal gesagt?
Die meisten haben 20?
Der Schweizer Durchschnitt
ist um die 35. - Ja.
Aber das kommt natürlich
extrem darauf an.
Wenn jemand Neues kommt,
kann man nicht sagen:
"Der hat soundso viele Stunden."
Das geht nicht, unmöglich.
Es kommt darauf an,
wie viel er privat fährt,
und auch,
ob man ein Feeling dafür hat.
Denn Autofahren hat absolut nichts
mit Intelligenz zu tun.
Es ist einfach ein Feeling.
- Aber es gibt dieses Klischee.
Speziell als Mann musst du es
von Anfang an im Griff haben.
Je weniger du brauchst,
ein umso coolerer Kerl bist du.
So ist es schon ein wenig, nicht?
Bei den Jungen ist es tendenziell so
verbreitet. - Ja, es ist schon so.
Meistens lügen junge Männer
nirgends so viel
wie bei den Fahrstunden
und im Schlafzimmer.
Was?
- Genau.
Okay.
Dort wird am meisten gelogen?
Wie viele Fahrstunden hattest du
und was läuft im Schlafzimmer?
Ja, das ist so.
- Okay, gut, also.
Also: beim einen möglichst viel und
beim anderen möglichst wenig. - Mhm.
Genau.
- Gut. All right.
(Für Mario gibt es Motorradstunden
statt Mittagessen.)
(Ich nehme ein Sandwich
mit Brigitta Kruszynski,
einer von zwei Fahrlehrerinnen
bei der Fahrschule Koch.)
Ich muss sagen, wir Frauen
sind schon noch in der Minderheit,
aber die Vorurteile nehmen ab.
Gab es diese,
als du angefangen hast?
Als ich angefangen habe, schon.
Ich musste mir
meine Reputation verdienen.
Aber ansonsten ist es
nicht mehr so schlimm wie früher.
Aber dieses miese Klischee
gibt es schon immer noch:
"Frau am Steuer, Ungeheuer."
Das hiess es doch mal.
Ja, natürlich.
Und Frauen können nicht parkieren.
Ja, ja. - Das lasse ich mir
natürlich nicht sagen.
Normalerweise ist es doch so:
Steigt ein Ehepaar in ein Auto,
ist zu 90 % der Mann auf der
Fahrerseite, die Frau daneben.
Erst nach dem Besuch,
auf dem Nachhauseweg,
wenn der Mann getrunken hat,
fährt die Frau. - Gell!
Weil sie weniger hatte oder nichts.
- Ein totales Stereotyp. Wieso?
Wenn sie gleich gut fährt,
warum fährt doch immer er?
Bei uns ist es nicht so.
Mein Mann fährt auch Auto, aber ...
Gut, du bist Fahrlehrerin.
- Damit hatte er eher Mühe.
Ich musste lernen, Kritik zu üben.
Das übte ich an ihm.
Ist nicht empfehlenswert,
aber mein Mann nahm das an.
Aber er ist noch dein Mann?
- Er ist noch mein Mann.
Auch nach 15 Jahren Fahrlehrerin.
- Darf ich dir die Hälfte anbieten?
Jetzt essen wir. Genug geredet.
- Jetzt essen wir.
Ich bringe nicht das ganze Sandwich
in den Mund.
Dieses Problem habe ich nicht.
(Brigitta lädt mich ein
zu einer speziellen Fahrstunde.)
(Es ist die letzte
ihrer Schülerin Samira.)
(Sie hat nämlich morgen
ihre Fahrprüfung.)
Willst du schon rechts?
- Ja, rechts.
Wir fahren bei der Glaubtenkirche
durch den Wald -
dein Lieblingssträsschen.
- Mhm.
Warum?
- Es ist auch so schmal.
Es ist sehr eng
und ein Bus fährt durch.
Ich bestelle den Bus immer.
Er kommt jedes Mal,
wenn du dort bist?
Ja, irgendwie schon.
(Samira ist cool. Ich soll doch
nach vorne sitzen, hat sie gesagt.)
(Bei der Prüfung sitze ja dann
auch jemand Fremdes neben ihr.)
Das ist wichtig, wegen der Velos.
Du hättest evtl. den Seitenblick
etwas früher machen können.
Der ist wichtig,
denn es hat einen Veloweg.
Die sind dann schnell.
- Ja.
Etwa so.
- Rechts.
Ich würde kurz warten, Samira.
- Schau, dein Bus!
Da ist er.
- Hier kannst du noch warten.
Dort vorne wird es wirklich eng
und der Randstein ist extrem hoch.
Ja, dort.
- Dort, wo die Velos sind.
Jetzt hast du den Bus erledigt.
Es kommt keiner mehr. - Ja.
Ich sage immer: nach vorne schauen.
Du siehst bis an die Kreuzung.
Hier ist es wirklich eng
und der Randstein ist hoch.
Wenn du den Ausweis hast, kannst du
mit dem Auto deiner Eltern fahren?
Oder musst du selbst eins kaufen?
- Dann gehe ich mit meinem eigenen.
Ah, du hast eins?
- Ja.
Du hast schon eins gekauft?
- Gleich als ich 18 wurde.
Nein! Du hast ein Auto gekauft,
ohne den Ausweis zu haben? - Ja.
All right. Sounds like a plan!
- Das ist sehr oft der Fall.
Nein!
* Lachen *
Blöd ist, wenn sie das Auto haben,
aber kein Geld mehr für Fahrstunden.
Ja!
- Das ist dann dumm gelaufen.
(Zurück in der Fahrschule.)
(Ich freue mich jetzt
auf einen Kaffee.)
(Brigitta gibt Samira noch Tipps
für die Fahrprüfung morgen.)
Du darfst noch keinen Kaffee nehmen.
- Okay, ist gut.
Okay.
Nein, was ist denn das?
Nein!
Was habt ihr da noch?
Jetzt holt ihr die Maschinen raus.
- Wir holen alles raus.
Nein!
Du meine Güte!
Was ist das für ein Teil?
Das?
- Ja.
Das ist exklusiv
für Menschen mit Beeinträchtigung.
Wir machen damit
sonst keine Fahrstunden.
Diese Menschen haben
riesige Geschichten hinter sich,
bis sie irgendwann wieder
in ein Auto sitzen können.
Die meisten hatten einen Unfall.
- Ja.
Wir wollten mal
eine irrationale Sache machen.
Wir sind ja sonst immer rational.
Das war unser Bubentraum.
Ein Maserati.
- Ein Maserati Quattroporte.
Ihr kauft euch
das Traumauto eurer Jugend
und rüstet es um für Menschen
mit Beeinträchtigung. - Das ist so.
(Ein schönes Bild: ein 100'000-Fr.-
Schlitten mit einem L dran.)
Ihr müsst ja auch
viel davon verstehen,
was mit einer Paraplegie
möglich ist.
Paraplegie, Tetraplegike,
Hemiplägie, Hirnschlag, MS,
ein Bein, ein Fuss, ein Arm - alles.
Wir hatten einen Rollstuhlfahrer
im Projekt, der uns beraten hat.
Er sagte: "Genau das muss es sein.
Es ist nicht zu verrückt."
Wir fanden: "Wenn du das sagst,
dann machen wir das."
(Mario) Viel Spass!
- Vielen Dank!
(Sie wollen Menschen, die sonst oft
am Rand der Gesellschaft sind,
hochheben und ins Zentrum stellen,
sagt Beat.)
(Eine Fahrt mit dem Maserati
kostet übrigens gleich viel
wie eine normale Lektion:
90 Fr. für 45 Min.)
* Tiefes Dröhnen *
(Wir holen eine Fahrschülerin ab.)
(Anita Rohrer, 58, hat wegen
einer chronischen Nervenkrankheit
immer mehr Mühe mit Gehen.)
(Deshalb lernt sie jetzt
neu Auto fahren.)
(Es ist ihre zwölfte Fahrstunde.)
- Morgen! Schön, bist du da.
Wie war das für dich am Anfang,
als du dieses Auto gesehen hast?
Ganz ehrlich: Mir persönlich
bedeutet das nicht so viel.
Für mich ist ein Auto
einfach ein Mittel zum Zweck.
Aber es ist total lustig,
die Reaktionen zu sehen,
wenn ich jemandem erzähle:
"Ich lerne im Maserati Auto fahren."
Die glauben mir das gar nicht,
sie beginnen zu lachen.
Sie denken, ich mache Witze.
Ist es okay, wenn ich hinten sitze?
- Ja, klar.
Halt dich einfach fest.
- Ja, ist gut. Ich gurte mich an.
(Ich fahre auf dem Rücksitz mit,
weil es bei dieser Lektion
Fingerspitzengefühl
und Erfahrung braucht.)
(Anita fährt das Auto nur
mit den Händen, ohne Fusspedale.)
* Blinker *
(Mit der linken Hand steuert sie
und mit der rechten Hand
gibt sie Gas und bremst.)
* Blinker *
Bravo, sehr gut.
Kreisel machten mich am Anfang
fast wahnsinnig. Es ist grauenhaft.
Das ist eine heikle Kurvenpassage.
Zieh noch etwas, Anita, zieh, zieh!
Ziehen heisst Gas geben, Mona.
Sie hat ja ein Ziehgas.
Ja. Aha, sie zieht, um Gas zu geben.
- Genau. Wieder etwas ziehen.
Wir fahren dort vorne gern links.
- Ist das wie im Flugzeug?
Genau.
- Man zieht ihn hoch.
Genau. Anita zieht ihn hoch.
- Ja.
(Gleich abheben kann man
auch mit dem Maserati nicht,
aber ein gutes Gefühl kann man
den Fahrschülern mit Handicap
vermutlich wirklich geben.)
(Vom einen Schüler zum anderen - das
ist das Leben einer Fahrlehrerin.)
(Vanessa wartet auf mich.)
Hoi, Vanessa.
Hoi, Mona. - Geht's gut?
- Ja. Dir? - Tipptopp.
Wollen wir anfangen?
- Ja, natürlich.
Gut.
Dann kannst du dich bereit machen.
Danke schön.
(Zum ersten Mal bin ich allein
unterwegs mit einer Schülerin.)
(Ich habe Regeln gebüffelt und
die ganze Fahrt genau vorbereitet.)
(Vanessa ist zum Glück
schon eine geübte Fahrerin.)
Was wäre das gewesen?
Ein Rechtsvortritt.
- Oh!
Hey, jetzt wäre ich ...
Hier wärst du an der Prüfung
wahrscheinlich durchgefallen.
Was haben wir hier?
- Rechtsvortritt.
Oh, da kommt sogar jemand.
Sogar die Polizei!
(Immer konzentriert,
immer läuft etwas.)
(Nein, langweilig wird es einem
wirklich nicht als Fahrlehrerin.)
Sie wissen nicht,
wem dieser Schopf gehört? - Nein.
Jetzt ist wenigstens Ordnung.
Beim nächsten Lichtsignal
gehen wir wieder rechts.
(Jährlich machen in der Schweiz
mehr als 130'000 Personen
die praktische Autoprüfung.)
- Super.
(Ein Drittel davon fällt durch.)
(Motorrad- und Lastwagen-Permis
kommen dazu.)
(Ich fand die Fahrschule
seinerzeit mühsam,
sie brauchte Zeit und kostete viel.
Jetzt wird mir bewusst:
Eine gute Ausbildung im Autofahren
ist wichtig -
lebenswichtig für die Sicherheit
von uns allen im Verkehr.)
* Eindringliche Streichmusik *
* Vogelzwitschern *
Mona, wie fühlst du dich?
Wie geht's dir bei uns?
Beat! Tipptopp.
Ich bin schon ein wenig verspannt.
Ich merke es.
Man ist immer so.
* Hupen *
Oh, jetzt! Schau her!
- Hallo zusammen!
Wer ist das?
- Flo.
Hast du Zeit oder habt ihr zu tun?
- Für einen Kaffee immer!
Mona. Freut mich.
- Freut mich, hoi, Mona.
Hey, great man! Hast du Ferien?
- Ja.
Flo ist vom Hals an gelähmt.
Er fährt besser als jeder,
den ich bisher ausgebildet habe.
Die Arme kann ich noch bewegen.
Aber du hast recht,
beim Hals ist der Bruch.
Du bist also Tetraplegiker?
- Ja, genau.
Ja, okay.
Und das ist dein Auto?
Ja, habe ich geklaut.
Nein, es ist meins.
Hattest du einen Unfall?
- Ja.
Du hattest einen Autounfall?
- Motorrad.
Motorradunfall? Oh, Scheibe.
- Ja, aber selber schuld.
Macht es das besser?
- Nein. Ja. Doch, schon. - Sicher?
Besser, du hast es selbst gemacht,
als einer überfährt dich. - Stimmt.
Du musst auf niemanden wütend sein.
Stimmt. Ausser auf dich.
- Genau.
Das interessiert mich jetzt.
* Piepen *
Deine Hand kommt hier rein?
Ja. Fahren wir eine Runde,
dann siehst du es.
Können wir?
- Ja.
Cool! Soll ich neben dich sitzen?
- Wo du willst.
(Flo hat sein Auto auch schon vor
der Prüfung gekauft und umgebaut.)
Fenster links schliessen.
Immerhin hat er nicht gehupt.
Manchmal versteht mich
die Sprachsteuerung falsch.
Ich habe schon kleine Kinder
am Zebrastreifen angehupt.
Du hast Sprachsteuerung?
- Ja, auch noch.
Oder: Wischwasch vorne!
Und Blinken ist am Kopf.
Aha!
Fährst du viel Auto?
- Ja, ich bin Bauführer.
Okay.
Ich bin oft
auf Baustellen unterwegs.
Wie einfach ist es,
damit zu steuern?
Ich stelle mir das
ziemlich tricky vor.
Den Joystick
finde ich nicht so schwer.
Das geht noch eher.
Aber das Bremsen ist recht schwer.
Soll ich hier mal hinfahren?
- Ja, wir probieren es, parkieren.
Du kannst mal lenken.
Aber langsam.
Oh, du meine Güte!
* Mona lacht. *
Oh! Sorry!
Am Anfang ist es schon ...
Auch du hast ja nicht gewusst,
wie es ist.
"Sind meine Arme genug stabil,
packe ich das?"
Hast du gedacht,
dass du es schaffst?
Ja. Sonst hätte ich ihn
nicht zuerst umgebaut.
Aber ich wusste nicht wie
und wie lange.
Aber irgendwie muss es gehen,
das wusste ich.
Und Beat war dann dieses Irgendwie.
Was bedeutet es für dich,
dass du Auto fahren kannst?
So komme ich selbst von Tür zu Tür,
egal ob Winter, Nacht ...
Das ist schon ziemlich viel wert.
- Ja.
Es gibt mir auch psychisch wieder
viel mehr das Gefühl, ganz zu sein.
Ja.
Ich musste während des Winters zwei
Monate lang mit dem ÖV zur Arbeit.
Ich fragte mich, wie das gehen soll,
wenn ich die Prüfung nicht bestehe.
Du kommst an den Arbeitsplatz
und möchtest dich gleich hinlegen.
Weil du so kaputt bist?
- Ja.
Dass ich bestanden habe, hat mir
wieder ganz neue Horizonte eröffnet.
Das war mega wichtig. Mega.
- Ja.
(Bei Menschen wie Flo
wird einem bewusst,
wie wichtig so eine Fahrprüfung
sein kann.)
(Weil sie manchmal
darüber entscheidet,
wie selbstständig man
sein Leben führen kann.)
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
(Bevor man überhaupt
zur Prüfung angemeldet wird,
macht man in der Fahrschule Koch
eine Vorprüfung.)
(So wie jetzt bei Joel.)
Da vorne gehen wir links,
dann gleich wieder links. - Ja.
(Ich muss die Expertin sein
und das bedeutet:
ernsthaft schauen,
klare Kommandos geben
und nicht reden,
wenn es nicht nötig ist.)
* Blinker *
Dort vorne
gehen wir bei der nächsten rechts.
* Blinker *
Hier kannst du
ein Bergsichern machen.
Du kannst dir einen Ort
an der Seite aussuchen. - Mhm.
Mit der Handbremse oder ...
Mit allem. So, wie du ein Fahrzeug
hier hinstellen würdest.
Mhm.
Dann würde ich die Handbremse ...
Und dann müsste man noch etwas
unter die Räder machen.
Ich bin leider dein Experte.
(Vorprüfung fertig - jetzt
darf ich endlich wieder reden.)
Fandest du auch,
Joel wirkte recht entspannt?
Extrem.
Wirklich sehr gelassen. Schön.
Mhm. - Was ist dein Gefühl
nach dieser Fahrt?
Es ist
mehr oder weniger gut gelaufen.
Hast du die Prüfung bestanden?
- Ich würde noch Nein sagen.
Nein?
- Ja. - Warum?
Beim Bergsichern habe ich
sicher etwas falsch gemacht.
Und vielleicht auch noch
zwei, drei andere Sachen.
Ich würde sagen, du hast recht
in deiner Einschätzung. - Mhm.
Ich als Experte würde auch sagen:
Es war vieles gut,
aber noch nicht so gut,
dass ich sagen würde,
du bist total ready zum Fahren.
Ich bin seit drei Tagen dabei,
fahre seit 25 Jahren Auto.
Aber ich bin bei der Testfahrt
auch durchgefallen.
Vieles mache ich auch intuitiv.
Teils kenne ich die Regeln
gar nicht, z.B. beim Einspuren.
Wo muss man Velofahrern
Platz lassen und wo nicht?
Eigentlich peinlich,
dass ich so unterwegs war.
Man kann es relativ schnell
wieder lernen, was gut ist.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen: Ich wäre
eine schlechte Fahrlehrerin.
Denn ihr müsst so viel wiederholen.
Immer Wiederholungen.
Das würde ich gar nicht ertragen.
Ich wäre zu verspielt
als Fahrlehrerin.
Ich machte die Fahrlehrerschule
mit 23.
Für mich war es eine Lebensschule.
- Wirklich?
Ich war noch etwas jung.
- Wie warst du vorher, wie nachher?
Es ist einfach ...
Du bist halt ...
Mit 18, 20
ist man noch etwas ungestüm,
im jugendlichen Leichtsinn.
Ich hatte das Schwein,
dass mein Vater Fahrlehrer war.
Er hat mir immer den Weg aufgezeigt.
23 Jahre war damals das Mindest-
alter, jünger durfte man nicht sein.
Aha. Ja.
- Genau.
Chapeau, wirklich.
Ich gebe es ehrlich zu:
Ich habe euren Job
zu Beginn auch etwas unterschätzt.
Ich würde diese Verantwortung
nicht übernehmen wollen.
Das würde mich einfach
zu stark belasten.
(Ich habe viel gelernt und gesehen
in diesen drei Tagen.)
(Aber jetzt
erleben wir noch den Höhepunkt
und gleichzeitig auch
den schwierigsten Moment
im Fahrlehrer-Dasein:
die Fahrprüfung.)
(Es gilt ernst für Samira
und ihre Fahrlehrerin Brigitta.)
Grüezi!
- Grüezi, Herr Maifredi. - Grüezi.
Hallo, Frau Zanin.
- Genau. Maifredi.
Hallo, Frau Kruszynski.
- Grüezi.
Vielen Dank.
Danke.
Ich gebe Ihnen das zurück.
Super. Also. Fit?
- Bereit? - Ja.
Legen wir los.
- Mach's gut! Tschüss!
(Bei der Fahrprüfung
kann man als Fahrlehrerin
keinen Einfluss mehr nehmen.
Brigitta kann nur noch warten.)
Sind Sie ortskundig?
- Ja.
Wissen Sie, wo der Bahnhof ist?
- So halb.
Fahren Sie einfach mal zum Bahnhof.
(Während der Prüfung selbst
dürfen wir nicht filmen -
eine Vorgabe
des Strassenverkehrsamts.)
Jedes Auto, das kommt ...
- Bist du auch nervös?
Ich bin total nervös, ehrlich.
- Gell.
(Dann: der Moment der Wahrheit.)
Sind sie es?
- Ja.
Ui.
- Macht sie den U-Turn?
Diesen Moment brauche ich
eigentlich nicht in meinem Job.
Da können alle anderen gehen.
- Ja.
Jetzt schauen wir, was passiert.
(Hat Samira es geschafft -
oder nicht?)
(Ernste Gesichter.)
Er hat Schreibzeug rausgenommen.
Hoffentlich nicht das Formular.
(Auch Brigitta wird unsicher.)
Oh. Nein.
Gut?
- Ja.
Nein!
(Also doch: bestanden!)
Es war wirklich hochstehend -
wie es selten ist, offen gesagt.
Ja, super.
- Hey, gratuliere ganz herzlich.
Vielen Dank.
- Sehr cool. Ich freue mich sehr.
(Zurück in der Fahrschule
warten noch die beiden Chefs
auf den Bescheid.)
(Brigitta hat ihnen
per SMS erst mitgeteilt,
dass der Experte
"einer der genauen" gewesen sei.)
Soll ich oder du?
- Sag du es.
Er hat ja den Experten gehört.
* Mona seufzt. *
Also das Expertenfazit war ...
- Herr Maifredi.
Herr Maifredi fand, es sei
eine interessante Fahrt gewesen,
weil es eine der besten war,
die er je hatte.
Wow! Wow!
(Die Erleichterung ist riesig -
sicher auch deshalb,
weil wir
mit unseren Kameras dabei waren.)
(Fahrprüfung bestanden,
Ziel erreicht.)
(Und das heisst bei einer Fahrschule
eben nicht "Auf Wiedersehen",
sondern "Adieu, merci!")